let me ask another question rob told me
that there was a recent discussion
of among the candidates where they were
asked
do you believe in god
and correct me if i'm wrong but five of
your candidates said no
uh and um this reminded me of a story uh
about the difference between europeans
and americans on the question of god
because in the united states in general
you would get into a lot of trouble in
politics if you answered no uh to that
question it's remarkable actually
somebody did a survey of how few
politicians including all the way down
in 435 members of congress 100 senators
there were only a handful who were
willing to say outright they were
atheists
and a french pollster and i were once
talking about this and as many of you
know the among the in the wealthy
democracies uh the united states has the
highest rate of church attendance or
synagogue attendance on a regular basis
uh and the french pollster and i agreed
that our american number is probably
inflated
and the french number is probably lower
than it is because americans felt guilty
when they didn't go to church and the
french felt guilty when they did
go to church
uh and so what i am wondering i want to
ask uh the question it's a personal
question i'll give you a third option uh
if you would like rather than ask uh do
you believe in god i want to ask do you
believe in god
or do you think god is possible or are
you quite sure there is no god how many
believers
are in the room how many people are as i
would say in the united states how many
will testify uh to their faith here
that's
that's a very substantial number that
might explain why you came to a
discussion on faith and uh
politics uh how many are in the middle
kind of uh think they might be there but
not sure or she
um
and how many are quite certain
that there is no god
um so i would say help me
count here
it's a rather close split but i would
say the non-believers outnumbered the
believers uh with a fairly substantial
uh
keeping their options open on the god uh
question
um and
i i think what i want to talk about a
little at the outset
let me ask you a question why do you
think before i talk anybody on any side
of this question why do you think it is
that the answer the political answer in
the netherlands the politically
convenient correct answer in the
netherlands is so different from the
politically convenient or correct answer
in the united states what what do you
think makes us different from the
netherlands or from europe on this
question any volunteers on the matter
please the the two you back there then
we can pass the mic
uh well the way i understand is that
it's a clear residue of the westphalian
piece in which a division between faith
and politics were
an answer to war in general once those
two were divided war would be
established in europe and if it was not
divided then war would still be possible
so it's seen as something necessary for
peace
i just say god bless you because i can't
think of very many people in an american
audience who would cite the piece of
west failure so that's that's a very
interesting answer it is it's sort of a
i i think a a philosopher called judith
schwar referred to it as a liberalism of
fear uh a fear that if we engage
in these questions too much in public
uh we will end up repeating uh the
religious wars and so you think that's
the uh that's the motivation the person
in front of you that's a very that's a
good theory uh i also think that it's
very closely related to the entire
manifest destiny idea and the american
dream and the
move westward and the idea that god gave
the right to the americans to be in
america
because
well that kind of i think if a
politician would step away from that
idea that he would be
not accepted anymore or not seen as a
serious american politician
so without god most of us wouldn't have
a right to be there well that's what
they believe right
or at least that's what manifest destiny
said
that's that's a very interesting idea
any anybody any other takers on the
difference between
europe or
over here
two let's do two more and then i want to
sort of offer my answer that's a good
answer too
i think it has to do with the fact that
in america you vote for a person i mean
you choose between romney and obama
and i think that we generally vote for
the party or we used to so for us it
doesn't i think it is a it shows
character if you're religious in america
and i think here
we don't really mind whether someone's
religious or not so it's about the
content of the party and not about the
person do you think by the way inherent
your question i've had conversations
with people inherent in what you just
said is the idea that dutch politics may
be moving more toward the politics of a
person person is that what you think is
happening it feels like that in this
election yes yeah
so might that change whether people care
about the religious beliefs of the
candidate or not
i don't think so i think we're really
accepting
of religion so
i think that doesn't really matter i
think character doesn't matter but
religion maybe not so much and then
there was one other person right next to
you yes sir
i think uh i think it's also a set of
values that's been disappearing
throughout you know when we
when you look at the netherlands in the
50s
we had like a system of values that's
very ingrained to our uh political
parties
and that's disappearing right now uh in
2012 and well earlier and that's
something you
if you look to america they still have
like uh well the political parties both
have changed but their image is still
kind of the same as it used to be in
like the 50s i guess
so
that's all
also a progression that happened in
europe
yeah that's that's interesting i i do
think that we can talk about this later
that the two parties have changed quite
a lot since uh uh the 1950s and in fact
that the two part two parties were in
some sense broad coalitions including
quite conservative and quite progressive
interests in both parties and there's
been a kind of uh sorting out but i i
think your other point is very
interesting and to the lady who talked
about character you're dead on according
to many pollsters um because you there's
a lot of polling that suggests that
americans whether they are believers
themselves or not but since the majority
vast majority say they are believers use
religious belief as a test of character
on the theory that somebody who is a
believer is more likely to create behave
morally uh in office one more before i
go on because he had an urgent hand up
in his eyes
america
believes more in god i think it is also
a matter of the distribution
of
of the
of the rich
or of the wealth i think it is also this
i think is also the distribution of the
world i think that uh religion is in
america
something as a last resort and not many
americans do have other options that
sounds like an all marxist the opiate of
the people uh analysis is that kind of
where you're coming from the uh there is
a um there was a great left uh left kind
of anarchist trade union movement in the
united states called the uh um
industrial workers of the world and they
put out a little hymnal of
songs of union songs and one of them was
rooted in that idea where the refrain
was you'll get pie in the sky when you
die
and then the next line was it's a lie
and so that was in that tradition uh
that you are
talking about